[Music]
thank you
in Jr tolkien's essay on fairy stories
he's got a section which is entitled
recovery Escape consolation and he's
going to discuss recovery first as being
one of the main functions of fairy tales
one of the uses that we can put them to
and he's going to begin with some
depressing thoughts talking about the
analytic study of fairy stories as being
a bad preparation for the enjoying or
writing of them and he goes on and he
says the study May indeed become
depressing it's easy for the student to
feel with all of his labor he is
collecting only a few leaves many of
them now torn or decayed from the
countless foliage of the tree of tales
with which The Forest of days is
carpeted it seems vain to add to the
litter and so he's got this great
metaphor here an organic metaphor of
this this tree that stories have grown
upon and then the stories fall down and
what are we going to do just collect a
few of these broken leaves we're not
going to you know grow a whole new tree
ourself and he says that who can design
a new Leaf the patterns from Bud to
unfolding and the colors from Spring to
Autumn were all discovered by men long
ago
so there's this sense of ah why why
recreate why reproduce something that
doesn't really benefit from us just
regurgitating the past and then
interestingly right after he says the
patterns were all discovered long ago he
says that is not true now it is true in
some sense many of the patterns were
discovered long ago
but the inference that somebody's
drawing is wrong and that's where the
truth in it uh disappears he says the
seed of the tree can be replanted in
almost any soil even one so smoke ridden
is that of England spring is of course
not really less beautiful because we've
seen or heard of other like events like
events never from the world's beginning
to Worlds and the same event there's a
newness a originality even in the
replication of the pattern he says each
Leaf of Oak and Ash and Thorn is a
unique embodiment of the pattern and for
some this very Year may be the
embodiment those of us who are older we
sometimes lose sight of the freshness
the newness that younger eyes may have
in perceiving these things and so he
goes on and he says
the first ever seen and recognized
though Oaks have put forth leaves for
countless generations of men so the the
tree is not because it's all just making
the same old stuff over and over and
over again as if it was in a poorly
drawn cartoon where they're recycling
the same basic scenes
it's a refresh it's ever new we have to
pay attention and attend and so he goes
on and he says we don't have to despair
of drawing because all lines must be
either curved or straight nor of
painting because there are only three
primary colors we may indeed be older
now insofar as we are heirs and
enjoyment or in practice of many
generations of ancestors in the Arts in
this inheritance of wealth there may be
a danger of boredom or anxiety to be
original and that may lead to a distaste
for fine drawing delicate pattern and
pretty colors or else to Mere
manipulation and over elaboration of old
material clever and heartless
and he says the true Road of escape from
this weariness is not to be found in
willfully awkward clumsy or misshapen
not in making all things dark or
unremittingly violent not in the mixing
of colors on through subtlety to
drabness and the Fantastical
complication of shapes to the point of
silliness and on to delirium these are
all as we can think about ways in which
people in
written uh language and visual arts in
other things try to recover some
originality none of these are actually
winning strategies you could say what do
we have instead Tolkien tells us that
before we reach such States we need
recovery
and he says we should look at green
again and be startled Anew but not
blinded by blue and yellow and red these
very you know blue yellow red primary
colors green one of the most important
secondary color we could add in orange
and purple and you know as brown and
black and gray and white when we look at
these we can say oh not just more the
same
we can recover something and he tells us
that fairy stories are going to help us
with that he says we should meet the
Centaur and the dragon and then perhaps
suddenly behold like the ancient
Shepherds things that are not imaginary
sheep and dogs and horses and wolves
this recovery he tells us fairy stories
help us to make in that sense only a
taste for them may make us or keep us
childish not childlike but childish so
what does this recovery involve he's got
a parenthetical one line where he tells
us that it includes return and renewal
of health and not just haileness of body
but that of Mind and Spirit as well we
should read in there so
that's important but even more important
is what he calls regaining a clear view
now this is quite interesting the way
that he describes it
he says I do not say seeing things as
they are and involve myself with the
philosophers now there is a lot of
philosophical discussion going on not
just in the Oxford of Tolkien but all
around the world at that time you know
very much oriented by epistemology and
metaphysics and the need to see things
as they really are right and Tolkien is
saying yeah I'm not worried so much
about that
I'm more interested in something else he
says that I would venture to say seeing
things as we are or were
meant to see them now there's a big
difference between seeing things as we
think they are and seeing things as we
are or Were Meant to see them there's a
teleology
involved in the second that's missing in
the first the a possibility not just of
reaching the end but of enjoying the
means of going along for the ride right
and then he's got this very interesting
discussion and this goes back to the you
know how to get out of these depressing
thoughts about what we need to clear our
Windows of to use the metaphor that he
brings up here so that the things seen
clearly may be freed from the drab blur
you know a similar thing with glasses
right every morning I have to clean
these glasses I'm not sure how they get
so smudged and dirty other than the fact
that I've got these big bushy eyebrows
which tend to get stuff on them and I'm
also kind of a messy person once I clean
the glasses I'm like holy crap look at
all this stuff around me whereas before
everything was kind of dingy and all
that now what is the dinginess that
Tolkien is trying to free us from so he
uses several different terms triteness
familiarity possession
he says that we need to free ourselves
of the drabler of triteness or
familiarity from possessiveness of all
faces those of our familiares are the
ones most difficult to play fantastic
tricks with and the most difficult
really to see with fresh attention
perceiving their likeness and unlikeness
that their faces and yet unique faces
the triteness he tells us is the penalty
of appropriation
of making it ours right the things that
are trite or in a bad sense familiar are
the things that we have appropriated and
he goes on he says legally
or mentally we've made them our own we
don't have to pay attention to them
anymore we can just you know take them
as being things and we don't have to
realize what they are and they're you
could say uniqueness in their presence
he says we say that we know them they
become like things which once attracted
Us by either glitter or their color or
their shape and we laid hands on them we
lock them in our horde acquired them and
acquiring cease to look at them how many
things do we do this with and how many
things do we do this with in terms of
stories or other types of art I've
already seen that van Gogh I don't need
to look at Starry star Sky again you
know that's been done to death well look
at it again with fresh eyes and maybe
you can recover some of the Wonder that
was there originally
now he goes on and he tells us fairy
stories are not the only way to uh the
only means of recovery of what we've
lost or prophylactic against loss
prophylactic means sort of a guard
against right something that will
preserve us from losing so we can
recover what we've lost we can also hold
on to what we've lost and he says one of
the things right off the bat humility he
says humility is enough and he doesn't
bother to explain that any further so
you know we don't have to say an awful
lot about it except that one of the
things traditionally humility is often
misunderstood as being like Oh I'm not
worthy I'm no good you know from David
Hume onward I would say where it's
called the Monkish virtue there's this
mistaken viewpoint on it right which was
even reflected in Mary woolstonecraft
around the same time a little bit later
than Hume who first use the word modesty
for what the Ancients and medievals and
early moderns called humility which
involves a right understanding of
oneself in relation to other things
humility opens the door for being able
to have a grasp on the unique
embodiments of the pattern or whatever
else we want to say then he talks about
two different kinds of fantasy he brings
up
chestertonian here he's talking about a
GK Chesterton right he says that there
is especially for the humble more fock
or chestertonian fantasy now more effac
is a fantastic word he says but it could
be seen written up in every town in this
land it is coffee room viewed from the
inside through a glass door as was seen
by Dickens on a dark London day and it
was used by Chesterton to denote the
queerness of things that have become
trite when they're suddenly seen from a
new to angle so coffee room is written
on the glass you're looking at the glass
but you're not looking at it straight on
from the front you're seeing It reversed
and they're like oh more effic that's
kind of funny right and you realize
what's there again the unique
embodiments of the pattern we we can
realize those because we see the things
that we formerly took for granted
through this kind of possessiveness this
triteness and we see them now as they
are meant to be seen and he says that
that kind of fantasy most people would
allow to be wholesome enough it can
never lack for material but it has I
think only a limited power
for the reason that recovery of
freshness of vision is its only virtue
it's only good quality it's great
but it's not enough
what about he says creative fantasy
so he says creative fantasy
it's trying to do something else make
something new may open your horde and
let all the locked things fly away like
caged birds the gems all turn into
flowers or flames and you'll be warned
that all you had or knew was dangerous
and potent not effectively chained free
and wild no more yours than they were
you and he says that the Fantastic
elements in verse and pros of other
kinds even when only decorative or
occasional help in this release so
creative fantasy goes beyond
chestertonian fantasy in helping us
unlock all of these matters that have
gotten too congealed to seized up so to
speak
but fairy tales go yet further according
to Tolkien he tells us that not so
thoroughly as a fairy story why because
a fairy story is a thing built on or
about fantasy of which fantasy is the
core now you might say oh well
fantasizing that's that's wonderful the
imagination and all that and here
Tolkien stops US short and says
something really important about fantasy
that he's going to reiterate elsewhere
fantasy is realistic right fantasy is
made out of the primary world
the world that we live in and then he
says but a good Craftsman loves his
material and has a knowledge and feeling
for clay stone and wood which only the
art of making can give by the forging of
Graham this legendary sword cold iron
was revealed we find out what iron
really is something that we take for
granted by the making of Pegasus horses
were ennobled in the Trees of the Sun
and Moon root and stock flower and fruit
are manifested in glory and he goes on
and he says fairy stories deal largely
mainly with simple or fundamental things
Untouched by fantasy but these
simplicities are made all the more
luminous by their setting fairy tales
set these things of our primary world
into a secondary world as he's going to
talk about sub creation and thereby
allow us to see things Anew to engage in
this recovery of what we've lost perhaps
even of what we never realized we had
lost that we think we're seeing for the
very first time